me
hello rz reacts reuben judah trust me
satyana ra yan nan
sup danny sup bruce evans sup fisto
peter what's up hunter hunter's in the
chat what is going on oh look it's
nellie cat you brought my chair i did
bring your chair
hello er body can you hear me all right
all right looks like everybody can hear
okay
let's try this
welcome back
miss alley cat
there we go
we gotta get you even move forward
but i'm
knocking
you gotta get past this part right here
just get past this part
we should be all right maybe not
yeah i'm saying it better if i'm like in
the back welcome everybody hello hello
hello
guys look look at this funko pop
look how big it is it's as big as it's
bigger than her head
that's big it's it's freaking huge
it's so cool we're giving this thing
away can it
i don't know where to put it we're
giving this away i'm keeping one for
myself but we are giving one away
well it's kind of like i need like
whatever it's right here it's right here
hello hello hello hello welcome who is
ready for uh let's kill this
and let's do this okay
i think
we are all good right now here you go
this will be for when it starts we'll be
watching it right here
i know everyone wants it the second we
show this everybody wants it because
it's sweet it's it's so cool
they got a little blue dot i saw that
what is that i don't know we're gonna
find out in the
movie there's a blue dot on his forehead
right here
yeah you can see it
hello hello hello welcome welcome
hello
mitixel
i think that's how you say that
is episode live yet no it is not live
yet it is not live yet
but we are ready hey there's mr anderson
that is ally yes the roommate what up
that's me
she has the channel marvel minute news
that i help her out with something we're
doing together so be sure to subscribe
to her hit that link right there i you
know what i'm feeling like if we move
the camera we won't necessarily have the
background but we'll be able to
hey thanks for donating through the
super chat oh here to do that uh not
live yet thanks for the super chat let's
see okay hold on
let's get a better spot here for this
camera
that's a bit better i just turned my
chair
you're not that much in the frame you
getting one there we go
there we go it's a little bit better and
we'll just advertise do you feel
actually i have a spiderman g fuel wanna
grab it for me oh yes spiderman
actually will
take this like
radioactive lemonade
i actually haven't tried it yet i
haven't tried it even we're gonna have
to try it right now live on screen
why don't you tilt the camera that's
fine
miles
prower
what is up what is up with no we don't
want to switch this we'll keep that
all right it's a new g-fil so check this
out it's the new spider-man one i don't
know if it's gonna focus
it's like literally the exact same
concept art they used
huh
there we go i don't have this set to
autofocus because i i don't
i choose not to well kingpin hawk well
kingpin kill hawkeye i
i don't think hawkeye's gonna die i
really don't also guys memberships are
not available for the channel you get
emojis i don't know
if i can show them
[Music]
can i put the emojis in let's figure
that out why aren't you letting me sign
in there we go
emojis do i get them i do
here's all
the emojis you get and yeah
sure
no cosmic wonder logo spiderman logo
woof woof logo i love you 3000
logo
if you feel like supporting the channel
go ahead become a member i'll be doing
some exclusive streams on there
eventually
just hit the join button next to the
subscribe button on the main channel
hey thank you
gaines burgers thank you so much
where do i subscribe there should be a
join button
next to the subscribe button
on the main youtube channel
maybe not maybe it's not up yet google
it
no it should
it should be that's what i do
google everything
it's easy i guess i can't subscribe to
my own channel not on mobile
yeah i don't know if it actually lets
you do it on
mobile i think you can only do it on
desktop i think you can only do it on
mobile if it's in the description
in the description yeah like if the link
is in the description
i'm not sure
let's go check it out
yeah i don't i don't think you can do it
mobile
i can't even do it on my ipad it looks
like yeah so you'd have to do it from
and i'd also just got to prove today so
maybe
maybe it's just taking a little bit of
time
i don't know uh oh
did we okay here we go yeah we're good
kind of froze for a second right there
there you go miss oh what up t nuts
nelson back for another super chat super
appreciate it
do you think the final battle
world will be the f
i think that battle world will be the
final finale in marvel franchise what
else they have left to do as big as that
also your mic is quiet
is this oh
is this any better
um i
i think it is gonna be a really big
finale
um i think it all leads up to that but i
mean a lot of people thought how are you
gonna do it after avengers in game
and here we are
doing live streams um
so i don't think i
i don't think
i don't think they're done after battle
world i really don't um
i think they're gonna go on i mean
think about how long dc has technically
been around for like think about the
first batman's and everything like that
like
you know the old old tv shows you know
it's been they've been around for a
while
i don't think they're stopping i think
it's going to go on they might change a
little bit
but uh
but yeah
make sure
come on
come on stop freaking out we'll do these
again
put my books down yeah
go become a member somehow
kingpin this episode auggie
stachelberg um i'm hoping we see more
um
thanks for that super chat okay i hope
we see more i hope we uh
i think there was a tease for like this
figure he was wearing like it almost
looked like she was wearing like night
vision goggles and like a full like
black suit i think that could be elena
for those of you who have seen the
finale or not the finale the post
credits of black widow spoiler alert you
should have seen it by now um
you know elena is told that hawkeye
killed
black widow and
she didn't
but she thinks that he did so we'll have
to see
we'll have to see
what are the predictions for this
episode do you think we'll see elena
i personally do you think that hooded
figure is yolena yes i do think so
but i also
we mentioned kingpin too
i don't know if he'll actually be shown
yeah i don't know either
i don't know i don't give an episode in
between that
like someone brought it up today then
about cliff hanging on the fourth
episode and i just thought about it i'm
like maybe they won't even bring up
kingpin again in this episode and
they'll just leave us hanging
i i think they might do like a
post-credit reveal
and that leads into the echoes but they
haven't had post credits yet
have some have
cosmic wonder should play daredevil
thank you game over jess jesse
sue thank you for the super chat oh from
south korea
appreciate it
thanks so much sue
glad you're back
w ricky
what is up love your channel been here
since one division still waiting for me
fisto hey thanks so much thank you for
the support thanks for sticking around
thanks for that super chat and yeah i
know right
eventually he shall come i'm i'm not
giving up on that i think eventually
mephisto will come maybe that's what
they do after battle world they bring in
mephisto
i need to move this because i can't
really see is the sound any better
more work
or where it shouldn't be worse
this is like right in between us
this should be all right
this should be all right test test test
test looks like we're going all right we
do have the fan on because it just gets
super hot with like all the lights that
we have on and everything so please bear
with us with that with that little
static noise we apologize about that but
i would we just it's really weird
because it's really cold outside but in
here it gets really hot so and now this
is cold all the time
alex is cold all the time
alley but yeah
there's so many nicknames
ali is cold all the time and if you have
not checked out ali's channel be sure to
do that mr anderson will randomly throw
it there in the check
there we go there we go what do i think
will happen the post credit scene in no
way home chiffon
i know
what happens in one of them
and i've done videos on that before so
like
i won't say it here because i know there
are some people who genuinely don't want
spoilers
so i won't say that um
um
but be aware of venom let there be
curtains just post credit scene
and i i only know one and i'll just say
something has to talk about multiverse
of madness right because this leads
right up into it
i still i'm still trying to wrap my head
around in the trailer where dr strange
says they're coming through
excuse me and i can't stop them
and we see like the purple but the
purple's not in some of the tv spots
did i miss this monarch thank you for
that super chat oh just got it
so this is definitely rumor it's not
going to be like any spoilers but here's
a
here's a super chat from monarch the
leaked post credit scene of episode six
is apparently val trying to recruit matt
murdock he declines and says he's gonna
stick around at nyc
that would be pretty cool
um
it would
it would be pretty cool if
there was some type of spider-man
post credit scene but since spider-man
comes out next week it's not we won't
have the post credit by then yeah unless
they plan to do like
a post-credit scene today because i
think
i can't remember was like loki or one
division did they did some post-credit
scenes before the final episode i
believe
i believe i'm not i can't recall it's
been such a long time it has how weird
been a really long is it was it all this
year was one division this year
was it really
wow
it doesn't feel like it like at all
like at all i mean it's december it's
been
a long year it's been a very long year
let's see if this is out
i don't actually 10 minutes i don't
actually know how to refresh just on
disney plus
how do i refresh this
not out yet
constantinos chara
chara lombos thank you so much for
subscribing i probably butchered that
but thank you thank you thank you what
am i saying no way home
uh next week
i think everyone's seeing it next week
uh one of it was february i think mr
anderson oh my gosh that it really
doesn't seem like it wasn't
i feel like it was last year for sure i
feel like like it was really last year
and i
i'm kind of baffled by that
to be honest like that's that's wow
t nasty nelson what is up do you think
the punisher is going to come back um
i hope
a lot of people have been asking me that
too yeah um
i here's my here's my here's my only
deal i would not get
i wouldn't get too focused on all of the
netflix characters coming back i know
some are charlie cox is daredevil kevin
feige said it
but but
don't don't don't make that like norm
for like everybody else coming back you
know what i mean
um
i wouldn't expect you know iron fist a
punisher i wouldn't expect everyone to
come back i think we're just kidding
i think we're just but always a
possibility
it is always possibility and i would
love to see the punisher back and i
think marvel should go down like a more
raunchy set
i think they need a darker side and i
think they are with like blade
and moon knight
and midnight yeah hey john c thanks for
the subscribe thank you very very much
robert andrews thanks for subscribing
appreciate it welcome to the fam welcome
i guess memberships aren't live right
now
um
well i can't subscribe to my own channel
so it doesn't work dave hill hey
another korean unless it's just you know
korean characters but welcome
hey corey robertson how's it going man
i've been talking a bit i might have to
check my uh
my uh dms on insta you might have hit me
up and i might have lost it
thanks nuts for subscribing
thank you thank you thank you thank you
[Music]
what will be my reaction if they
introduce fisk in this episode
um
i'll freak out i mean
i freaked out in the last episode where
i was like that's freaking kingpin and
all we saw is just a big figure in his
arm
and um
i'm very curious if we see him
i'm just kidding i'm
as i kind of talked about the last time
after when someone went to sleep i
worked yes yes she does work in the
morning um
i i
i think there's a lot happening and i
just feel like it's
interesting to throw all these people in
it but i think it works with the story
where's the love for ben affleck's
daredevil augie thanks for that super
chat i i didn't mind ben affleck's
daredevil i know it was a long time ago
and a lot of people might not have seen
that movie um but jennifer gardner i
think that i think that's the actress i
i kind of get the jennifer's confused
sometimes
there's a lot of jennifer's who are
really good actresses um
but she
with as cleopatra like the whole story
with uh and the kingpin and that i loved
it like i i liked it i really really
liked it i really really liked it
um
gaines burger so i think we'll see
kangan uh i do not thank you i do not
think so i do not thank you
no i thank you for that super chat and i
don't think so
uh
aditya
thank you for subscribing i'm so i
probably butchered that
i'm trying i really am trying is it out
yet not yet apparently oh i can't
sneha pratik
cobra god day i'm so sorry but thank you
for subscribing i i'm so sorry i i know
i did not say that right
sri milan nj
well it's like uh
it's like a good time in india right now
right like
it's not
one in the morning for y'all
reckless noob thank you for subscribing
hello hello hello everybody hello jd
ultra how's it going
hello sword welcome back i think uh
i i think kingpin
tbz am thanks for subscribing um
i didn't realize i actually did all this
alerts yeah i don't know if i can
you can turn them off yeah okay um
you're watching eternals today robert
andrews um
it's hard for me to tell you because a
lot of people do like it's very split i
i personally really really enjoyed the
movie i really liked it a lot um
but there were some people who didn't
so
i had a lot of both ways a lot of both
ways
bradley jones thanks for the super chat
do you think we'll get king before
antman three we kind of already have
in
loki not not exactly king but nathaniel
richards
um so
we kind of already have to i think we'll
see him like again probably not i'm i'm
i think it's gonna stay for ant-man
uh t nasty nelson thanks for the super
chat still mad the leader is still a
loose and an mcu leader of
what
sorry did i miss something the leader
did i did i miss something um
yeah sorry if i if i if i missed that
um
not really sure what you mean by the
leader
of the
thunderbolts dark avengers like um val's
boss or
trying to think i'm just trying to
connect it all i'm sorry i'm uh i'm not
i'm not i'm not following i'm sorry
will thomas h church play sandman i
i don't know i would like to think so
oh we're talking about the hulk
um
i'm not sure they'll address that guys
um i'm actually really surprised that
spoiler in chiang chi that
i mean it was in the it was in the
trailer so i guess it's not a spoiler um
they showed abomination you know like
i'm actually pretty surprised that we
saw abomination
so i've been montoya thanks for that
super chat appreciate it two minutes
two minutes
it should be out already
i'm just calling two minutes you you're
calling two minutes all right
yeah um nelson thanks for clarifying
that you didn't have to super chat that
again but i appreciate it i you know i
in my mind marvel studios the mcu is
trying to
clear
like stay clear from the incredible hulk
movie like i mean they even recast the
actor right i mean it
i don't know if they'll address that or
i don't know if that's who val is
working for you know that that i always
think that could be a possibility oh no
imperfect lioness
been watching disney plus marvel series
along with you since one division you're
so fun to listen on the show oh thank
you so much i super appreciate that
very very very much appreciate that
i hope we continue to
entertain and provide some sort of
provide you know something extra to the
show um
nice moomoo machines
spiderman home comes out tuesday so
excited i would be super excited as well
thank you for that super chat
move machines i love it
love it level it oh you know what i
should do this
uh oh
yes yes you should
just to make sure i didn't miss any
doesn't look like i've missed anything
just want to check though
what is today december 8th
these are all i might have missed them
uh maybe i didn't
okay here we go okay got it got it got
it got it
got it
got it
got it
got it
yeah cool okay just make sure i don't
miss any super jets
super appreciate you all so oh
just got one for bradley
uh
justin hammer return although he didn't
have any powers i thought he was
actually a really good villain bradley
jones super super chat i really hope him
because i like sam rockwell the actor
who plays him he is like some wicked
good dance moves and i don't know why
but i've always really liked that about
him like i always just i've always have
um i think he's a phenomenal actor and i
think he it would be a great
a great thing to see hammer return maybe
maybe like be the thunderbolt be for the
thunderbolts
i s in
x thunder
thank you for the super chat give a
shout out so
if you donate i'll say your name
but besides that i don't do shout outs
uh because everybody always asks for
them but thank you for the super chat i
appreciate it okay people are saying
it's out
one minute ago one
no shut up
okay
partners am i right secrets are revealed
and hard truth submerged culminating
in a battle against two opposing forces
i forgot to hold please oh gretch oh
gosh i forgot to do this
the timer the timer how could i forget
how could i forget the timer i don't
think you're going to want to be
be counting that
new window
we're going to do this we're going to do
google
you're on 30 seconds
30 seconds oh be quiet all right
we're going to be starting we're going
to count it down
hey ice and thunder thanks for another
one another shout out there you go i
think the camera's a little low
all right we're going to be counting oh
no no no we're going to be counting
we're about to start this in three two
one
i have started
and then let's
that's not it
oh so sad i know where he was he
couldn't talk to his phone as his kid
oh gives me goosebumps
dang it okay we have to move this over
here then
move this over here
like spy music
yeah
that time yeah and didn't pause it
wow
all right cool
i love all these comments
all right
this is kind of in the way of the screen
and as as we did last time i'll randomly
just turn this and show you guys kind of
what we're watching here you can hear it
yeah yeah
oh spiderman g fuel it is time
please be amazing
i mean it's lemonade
oh it's so good
it's refreshing oh i love it
it's very refreshing
that is really good
it's got like sparkles all right here we
go
why is there an avenger in my
your archer
what's the point of discount kit
harrington
that's so funny pass on written thank
you i think we'll find out
but thank you for that super chat
how terrific
wow hawkeye come on
dude wonder who that was
cb1
what's her age gap what's my she's 22
and he's 44 42 huh
[Laughter]
thank you for saving the world
oh yeah
avengers level threat
say it
yes
he admitted that he's working with kate
and she is so happy
oh he sees that as the ronin sword
we're not done yet
so they don't know i thought he knew
jack for sure in the comics they do in
the comics jax's mentor
uh her her handles are alicat official
right
twitter
alicat official a-l-l-i-k-a-t
oh
dang no way
it's funny that she
yes
she's a bad guy
she's bad
so right now she's just talking to she's
just talking to hawkeye saying
this is my daughter like she can't die
like
you'll forget this case
she has to forget so she literally asked
him to forget the case i'm i feel like
she's bad i just feel she gives up i
just i think she's madam mask i just
really do
come on
yeah i think you're as close to me
can you run sloane ltd for me please
laura his wife fiesta's wife to do that
interesting oh what's she going to say
here's
we have
being sneaky
what
oh
oh
oh so
jack's in charge of the tracksuit mafia
the rolex
what is the
what is the rolex
nice them if you have to such a good
wife she should be icing them for him
nathaniel groans
wow
how is she listening
oh she's right there literally right
there
so jack's going to get t while eleanor
and kate talk
can we change the subject she wants to
talk about jack
yes so eleanor
she's such an evil vibe
and that's why i thought jack was
innocent because
he seems like
he really seems like he's evil which
makes me believe he's not evil
christmas music
oh she she smiled she thought it was
cute
kate smiled she but like
look she's smiling
oh
please don't be evil jack i want you to
be so good now i know
uh
este don vic
thank you for that super chat maybe
he's too hot guys home
absent makes the heart grow older
i like him i really hope he's not evil
but like in this section
what just like in this part yeah he
seems like he's
i'm
gosh disney plus is such a good job at
like really confusing you and making you
wait till like the final freaking
episode to figure everything out like
you
so right now hot guy is uh icing himself
up
how do i i don't know i'm trying guys
i'm really trying
i know you can see like my camera and
everything behind it but you're not
missing much right now
oh somebody's there to see hawkeye
poor guy
it's not going to be kate
is it
it is it is kate
kate's there to see hawkeye
[Music]
the classic hawkeye costume
i like i like
he's gonna love her by the end
talk about sword boy oh what does he
know
and turns out
jack decane is the ceo
of a money laundering company for the
tracksuit mafia
i like your spirits here we go i like
the spirits
wait
where's the
where's the car i want to see the comic
accurate
that is not the comic accurate okay
no
attraction mafia
okay not focused
oh no
oh and that's her uh famous on
oh
hey debbie welcome yeah we're 12 minutes
into it
i won't say anything
right now for
boomerang arrows
coming back at us boomerang eras you'd
have to dodge and then dodge again so in
one of the episodes they're going to use
a boomerang era and it's going to like
save their lives or something
i've done it a few times
i'm making a baby tree
quarter nickel or dimes too
prove it all right
hot guys
i mean it is hawkeye gosh they are
getting drunk
they're flicking
she hit lucky
all right she's going to use this trick
to knock somebody out or being her
oh [ __ ]
well she did it am i missing something
in the comments i don't know
mr anderson's kicking butt
never mind shouldn't have said it
does he have a cat
she got this water for him i know
come on best shot you didn't take
say it
all right
oh he was supposed to kill
he was supposed to kill natasha but he
didn't he flipped her instead
because it was natasha
it was black widow
it's really sad
um
game of managing loss
that sounds very very sad
i know natasha's gone but like she
sacrificed herself to save half the
universe
so like
so it's okay
it's not okay
oh this is did you lose your family the
blip
yeah
wow
do what you got to do mr anderson
is that where you met the ronin oh my
gosh please tell her that it was you
he is
that's where i became the ronin
say it
she'd be down inside no it's you isn't
it
hurting people
um
she's trying to help him through it
well i mean it keeps coming back to
haunt him
no but she just found out you'd expect
maybe a little surprise
oh
no
okay i better make it home for christmas
i swear
so
like we haven't even seen any villains
besides jack but we've seen nothing
with echo or the tracksuit mafia i want
to see kingpin
where's jelena
well this is
a little slower paced episode but
there's some important things happening
she just found out that
he's ronin like takes his hearing aid
off i feel like
i feel like he should not take his
hearing aid off
ever
yeah i feel like you could always oh wow
oh they're really she's relieving it the
very beginning from avengers in-game
yeah
oh
oh snap ronin footage ronin footage
natasha footage
oh my gosh
three days until christmas dang
dang
thanos was right it does say it on the
mug somebody pointed that out
me
they're colorful you're gonna love them
the larpers
are arrows
go get our arrows
all right here's the larpers
oh this should be interesting
super power doom
killing it
kate says i'm his partner slash best
friend
arrows
oh
there's a grills
she promised them something hawkeye's
gonna have to
hawkeye's gonna have to freaking
do he's gonna have to do another larp
with her with them
trust the bro
ice wall
i just want to talk
oh no
you seem like a reasonably not stupid
guy
way off the mark
william lopez
that was maya's father
maya's boss come on
you know what he's already done to get
it so he wants the rolex
wanting to hunt running down it's
dangerous okay
[Music]
so does he i'm confusing
if he knows maya
[Laughter]
i don't think she listens to him she
didn't want to do them last time
oh hawkeye just said this is the final
warning
can i have my gun back what do you think
good luck
oh he threw us his gun
he left-handed
burnt cookies lovely
oh no
all the larpers are at the apartment
huh what is going on
get my gear
i look pretty good as viking
that guy's like not having it hug is
like
materials for the new costume
welcome back accelerator
not stage of play
we're killed oh gosh the rolex wasn't
destroyed at the avengers compound the
transmitter is signaled from this
location
37 3715 godfrey road
era retrieval mission complaint
huh
bombshell
bombshell
all right hawkeye has located the rolex
i
i have no idea what it is yet no i'm
confused with that too
the rolex
it's the rolex are talking about but
like what's the rolex was the avengers
compound what is it for it's pinging
it's important
oh i like that
i want to prioritize a quick exit over a
quick entrance
sounds more to me
is she gone she's gone
okay
she's just walking up
your inability to act like so i could
it's just a slight tweak though
no
don't engage she's helping all the old
man in with her bags come on
what a gut what a girl
okay
way to be weird
oh gosh
why is it what
she literally just okay
kate is just so funny what was that
about hawkeye has a collapsible bow she
doesn't that's funny
why is why is the watch in this
apartment
whose apartment is whose apartment is it
i thought i heard a dog but i think it
was a yeah it was door squeaking
sensors
strobe lights attached to the wall
oh shoot
a vintage rolex
as long as someone used to work with
they've been out of the game a long time
oh there it is
don't get too excited
i really want to know what the freaking
watch is about i wonder if it's
daredevils
part of his family yeah
get out now get out kate
oh oh no
get out of the apartment oh my gosh
oh
knocked her out
it's gotta be elena
oh that's gotta be elena oh her mask
came off
okay
go
it's gotta be elena
okay it's gotta be elena who the heck is
he fighting
it's so dark
[ __ ]
that works please show us elena come on
yeah it's elena it's a woman for sure
oh freaking then this girl she was
probably about to show us who she was
where is maya she just kicked the other
one
and she
yeah that is yolena that is black widow
movements
oh it's elena those are black widow
bites
well that's a cool way to introduce her
that was oh step
she like she lodged her to something
oh
thank goodness for christmas oh
wow
that is elena she used black widow bites
that was such a cool way to introduce
her
now clint's fighting two people
okay
nice a sonic blast arrow
yeah as if hawkeye wasn't deaf enough
take it off take it off take it off
holy hell she kicked kate far
oh
she shot her with an arrow
she actually hit her is she running
all right this is he's going to grab her
and he's going to be like why do you
have black widow
that was her
yeah look at that it's freaking her
hey
[Music]
kate did not expect that
okay
so she she left
you don't want to know
oh
oh god okay
someone has hired a black widow assassin
wow oh no
she's got very real very quickly i'm
doing this alone he wants to protect her
he was once protector she will die
oh
he cares about her too much
she's a kid yeah
well when he
made the mistakes or whatever
he's seeing them
it's over
he has to do he has to do it he has to
do it i mean
and that's gonna be the end of the
episode freaking a well there's the
elena reveal
oh that's what you're excited about
all right hold on
i'm just saying i told you kingfin
wasn't going to show up and he didn't oh
goody
there's two episodes left
does not appear to be a post-credits
scene
well
okay wow
that was pretty sick i
uh
i liked uh i liked the elena
introduction oh but did i call it i
called the elena apart i said the girl
that has like the night vision goggles
on that's elena bulova i freaking
definitely did freaking called it
hold on a second
i think i'm gonna go and join the
discord call
on my computer i took your camera oh
never mind i can't do it without your
camera
i hear i hear chris
no i don't hear chris
hold let's uh let's figure this out
let's get chris in here
also
turn on camera
[Music]
we're still here okay we're still here
um
let's do settings let's do
all the input
no
no
i
why
why not
i can connect your airpods to my phone
and go through discord there
so i can hear dressy there
can't hear him i think it's on my end
though chris
chris
come on
i don't i i literally no idea what the
problem is
test it says i'm talking so that means
test it can hear me which means
what's your output
well output would be
oh
yeah
chris you can hear us
chris
hello
chris
chris
chris
hello
hello
i can hear you
i cannot get the video to share though
well i'm using a separate camera
and i don't know yeah i don't know why
that's not
working
i mean
camera game capture i mean
that's it that's the one which one that
one live streamer yeah it's called
hey look at those pretty people we got
it
no
so how do i how do i put how do i put
both there we go i can
just make
i think we're okay here guys hold on
thank you
how do what now how do i do this hold on
there we go
so here's a question could everybody
hear everybody
on my side
yes
you're gonna hear chris try twice
because for some reason oh you know what
i know why
oh hold hold i think i just figured this
out hold on
yes i would like to switch
input only
chris
can you hear me
yeah oh you know what you have to do it
that way though because
then i can can you still hear me
can see the tv
so
better or worse than the last episode
the last episode was really good not as
exciting
not as good i thought it was better
really
i like this one i think every episode
has gotten better
why
i don't know the action in this episode
we got some really cool flashbacks from
hawkeye we got a little bit of that deep
emotional stuff in pocket which i
personally think is going to be that
story to know the character
um the whole hawkeye mission of breaking
into the house was really cool
okay so they can't hear you now
dang it
so they didn't hear the echo only you
did
well no because you're coming through my
speakers
device
says it was a better episode okay
we i think we can hear you now i can
hear the tv by the way no kingpin
no no
that's what ally is happy about ali said
she just ali said her prediction in the
beginning was no kingpin and i'm what
and she's like no kingpin i'm like oh
yay for all of us have you have you
ever seen in 2000
in like 2010
there was an octopus
that correctly guessed all of the
knockout levels of the world cup they
would put two pictures of the team's
logos in this in the tank and he would
swim over to whichever one
one and he was right about all 16 games
there was no actual knowledge or skill
involved he just guessed right every
single time
[Music]
that octopus doesn't even know what a
soccer ball is right yeah well i know
what a kingpin is the most important
question is does the lesbian woman get
her bombshell bag back
the answer is probably
does she get it back that's
i'm gonna say no they made it a big deal
yeah i don't think there's much to it
so i have a question
i think
did eleanor call kingpin
oh 100 she must have done
they they're obviously deeply connected
in it yeah let's see sanchez actually
said it right there bishop's mom called
kingpin yeah i mean i i definitely think
she'd call it kingpin
oh i agree 100
yeah i mean
they've got to be heavily involved in it
i've oh i'm piecing it together now what
if she what if she just put everything
in jack's name
oh jack doesn't have a clue jack doesn't
have a clue that's it that actually is
gotta be that is so marvel he is too
obvious he is too obvious way too hard
to be a villain she totally did that
under his name he has no idea i bet
that's it i couldn't see that i bet
that's it i can't just
an unsuspecting lover of of this lady
and he has no clue what's happening
anything she's just some lady that runs
a security company
right
that is the marvel way to do it i'm not
gonna lie i think he's just a guy who
likes swords
and is good looking suspicious
i'm i'm looking at you irl i'm literally
turning around
because allie whispered in you're here
right
yeah she told me she's like hey warren
here's what you do allie is the eleanor
and i am the jack
[Laughter]
so there you go
i'm just i'm talking i'm the i'm the
pizza dog
by the way the spiderman g fuel is very
good
is it did you try it ally yeah i did
it's really good it's really refreshing
because it's like oh i love refreshing
drinks we're gonna have to go buy like a
hundred of them
yep
jack the scapegoat yeah you heard it
here first guys i haven't heard that
anywhere yet i actually genuinely
believe that is me ali slash warren came
up with that idea on their own
and uh you'll definitely be hearing that
in a in a breakdown video tomorrow and
then in subsequent other people's videos
following oh for sure for sure
i truly bel i that is what i believe now
that is what's going in my brain oh that
is so marvel though that is so hard i
feel like that's just
i just really feel yeah let's just
screen record this moment
and we can go to bed early warren yeah
right hey can you see my memberships up
i don't think they're up yet i don't
have a button for it uh it takes a
second uh i'd have to pull it up on pc
let me do it real quick so sorry for
everybody who i told about memberships
that were up i don't think they are uh
let me go to the wonder
if they might just not be on no they're
not up
but if you want to be a member mine are
up
chris's are up
and i have some dope emotes of spiderman
go in
i
i really i i think that is what i think
i think
i think jack is uh mr anderson said it
patsy
uh william lopez is maya's father
um for the for the person who as jace um
i think that's it i i'm calling it i
mean i'm convinced i completely 100
agree with you i think jack is innocent
i think
yeah i really think jack is innocent and
i think eleanor is this behind
everything and she put stuff in his name
i think i think she could possibly
be working
with or for kingpin
probably working with him at the very
least you know or like one level
underneath him because they mentioned
him a few times right yeah
how about that scene with hawkeye and
his wife
where she's all involved speaking german
and that was really really cool i
actually really liked that
there were a lot of cool things to this
episode
yeah half of it was spent more than half
of it was spent
almost like
no bad guys knew nothing you know what i
mean
and i think the action and the arrows
and everything in the last episode was
so good
that's true um which is why i'm like hey
um
yeah that's why i think i like the
information i like the story i do too
number one i'm never one to be like oh
it was slow so it sucked that's not what
i did right and i do really i really
liked
yelena showing up oh that was awesome
her gear and all of her stuff
yeah the scene she used the black widow
bites i was like oh yeah i know i was i
was pretty sure the second that he said
i don't know who i'm fighting i'm like
who's it gonna be right
right so it's like um i'm super excited
to see where that leads because i think
out of everything we're gonna see in
hawkeye that's one of the biggest
connections to the movies moving forward
because we're getting all these disney
plush shows the echo disney plush show
and kate bishop might even get her own
you know but i think that whatever's
going on with her
is gonna most
quickly connect to the main mcu yeah for
sure king j thank you for that super
chat i like that last episode a little
bit more but the action in this episode
was better oh you actually think the
action was better i i did really enjoy
i thought it was kind of cool that it
was like
it was
like three fights going on
you know
like it was hawkeye versus elena and at
the same time it was kate versus uh maya
but then at the same time it kind of
became like maya versus kate versus
elena versus yeah everybody's fighting
each other
ago and then it was weird
i do i did like that i did like that
um we're not gonna spend a lot of time
in the in the chat tonight or uh doing
the discussion tonight
but uh what do you guys think what do
you think what do you rate it
and i'm still calling it i i i think
jack has no idea what's going on eleanor
is the bad guy because he's just way too
obvious to be the bad guy they're like
here he is here's the bad guy it's like
no sleight of hand right yeah yeah you
watch here but really over here i'm
doing yeah i agree with that theory 100
yeah i think i don't like to raid out of
10
because it's hard to do rate out of five
no i'm gonna just rate them in order and
this was my favorite one that's how i do
it like
this hawkeye series this is my favorite
episode i it's either this episode or
the last one for me but i do think it's
either the first or second best
yeah and then if you want to like go
even deeper into it so far i think
hawkeye's probably my third favorite
series
behind obviously loki one division i'm
still not sure which order between those
then hawkeye then falcon then what if i
like this more than falcon so far i
think i would rate it
the same
yeah and then this was my favorite
episode out of the
what what ally no get your own opinion
get your own opinion mine this one's
taken
i didn't say it was your opinion i
didn't like it because it's christmas
all right the last thing we're going to
talk about who does the watch belong to
thank you i wanted to talk about the
watch before we stopped what did we
learn about the watch
it was in maya's apartment or was it in
it was in my apartment it was in maya's
apartment it used to be in the avengers
compound
and if somebody thought it was destroyed
right and if somebody finds it it'll
reveal the identity of somebody
right so who it's got to be somebody
kind of important she was saying your
family's writing notes
what if it's furies
no because everybody knows who fury is
though
right the whole thing is finding fury
and fighting him but everybody knows who
he is it's got to be somebody we don't
know i think i think it's going to be a
huge reveal i think i think it's
probably somebody we don't know because
if you think about
the avengers
everybody knows who the avengers are
right so
so who would clint have contact with
that we could kind of guess and be aware
of
that would have been involved with the
avengers from you know the infinity war
area era
like i'm trying to think who it could be
because there's very few
options i think
like we honestly if we sat down and
thought about it we could narrow it down
it could just be his wife talking about
you know it's got to be his wives
yeah it could be we don't know she
clearly can do stuff
speaking all these things obviously very
capable yeah she can obviously do things
right maybe she worked for shield and
it's like her
file is somewhere on the watch somehow a
microchip or something yeah
because she knew what the watch was as
well you know out of all of the things
in the avengers compound she knows about
why would the watch be one of those
things yeah oh man
because i think it's either his wife's
and she's done stuff over time that we
don't know about maybe she was like how
did they get together we don't even know
maybe yeah maybe she was an agent for
shields and she retired right and she
caught it and that's all all of her
information is on the watch in a
microchip inside the watcher maybe she
was a black widow maybe her with natasha
maybe that's maybe that's why she's so
close with natasha as well and all of
them are so comfortable with clinton
natasha being so you know what i mean
yeah yeah yeah absolutely
king james thanks for another super chat
i thought the watch was the same watch
that iron used in civil war
but it's not it has a deal with someone
who's important
it also seems kind of old though
like i thought maybe it was howard's
i'll take a look yeah i it seems kind of
old it's a vintage rolex right i think
it's his wife's or someone we don't know
and i'm gonna i i'm actually liking my
theory about maybe she was a black widow
before dude that would actually be kind
of fire that'd be a really cool review
because he seemed to really know at the
end he got it got real serious
and yeah that's worried and i think he
might be worried because maybe his wife
was a black widow and now there's more
black widows coming and now it's like
holy crap like it's serious now like my
wife might be in danger like this is
really serious todd andrew thanks for
the super chat eleanor killed arm 100 i
agree totally agree
everybody here agrees
he figured out kate's mom true motive
and kate's mom used jack as a fall guy
hundred percent yeah because remember
armin was trying to he kept he even told
kate like
oh he thinks eleanor is a dream come
true or whatever he's won the lottery
with her and he's like and i told him no
not so sure
i think i think eleanor figured out what
was going on
i think um
or uh sorry armand figured out what's
going on with eleanor
he was trying to protect his nephew
it's his dad in the comics nephew in the
series and she killed him because he
figured it out kingpin all blah blah
blah blah right um
yeah todd thanks for super chat 100
agree hi
oh i think i think we figured out the
whole series right now go on
have a good night madega thank you for
joining us you know
well we do have to get started on the
breakdown i have one more question
before we sign off
last time we talked a little bit about
the fate of hawkeye
are you more sueded one way or another
after this episode
i don't think he's gonna die i mean is
that because you don't want him to die
or because you actually don't think he's
gonna die because i don't want him to
die i'll actually be pretty upset if he
dies i don't think he needs to die i
don't think
marvel would do that
i just don't think there's a reason
there's no reason there's no reason just
kill a man with a family for no real
reason right i mean besides like oh yep
let's make it so let's have steaks like
i get that
but when you have such a christmasy
family
why would you just kill somebody right
oh everybody disney plus let's watch
this let's watch all this this christmas
show every night right before christmas
the last episode comes out dead hawkeye
that's true yeah i don't think disney
would do that i just i don't i don't
think they would do that i just really
no okay so all three of us are saying no
okay that was the last thing i wanted to
talk about before we hopped off because
i know we've got a lot of work to do
today
yeah oh lackey one thanks for the super
chat laura has kids so she can't believe
a widow that's that's a good point maybe
that is a fair point maybe that is a
fair point
maybe i don't know i feel like she could
have been just maybe just another um
like spy for another
another country and she
and natasha and her got pulled out at
the same time like i think that might be
would it be but lacking something like
that that is an excellent point because
they do make it to where they can't have
kids
vv champ somebody in warren's chat
actually just pointed out she can't be
an ex black widow because she had kids
and all the black widows are incapable
of having
a very good right
so uh so she's not gonna be a black
widow but she could be some type of spy
that knew natasha worked with her
because she was very friendly with
natasha during the encounters right and
that's what i was thinking like she was
very very friendly with natasha which
leads me to believe like maybe she was
friends with natasha before clint and
clint saved them both
from something and that's why they were
all comfortable with each other because
to me i was like man clint natasha are
like really close but
she's also really close with his family
as well they call her aunt nat and
everything like that yeah so it's not
just like
yeah there's a connection there we'll
see
somebody in my chat says la chica
i think they're talking about you warren
what's it let you guys hermosa yep
but yeah i'm good with that those are
all the talking points i'm excited to
see what happens with jilenna i'm glad
they got her in this episode and then
just like leave some weird cliffhanger
because i'm i'm curious
about a lot of stuff that she's
connected with so
good one good episode they're only
getting better which i'm glad because
they started off a little slow
yeah the this is definitely one of the
better of the four i would say top two
of them i mean we only have four so far
but for sure we only have two episodes
left so
stuff's gonna go down next episode i
think yeah stuff gonna go down yeah king
j another one kate mom told hawkeye to
close the case not to leave kate out of
this that was super oh yeah it was super
such because she's behind it all right
she's running the tracksuit mafia i
think jack has zero idea
he's gonna set up like mr anderson said
oh poor jack and i actually liked jack
in this episode and kate liked jack she
was smiling and she was like wow i've
never seen you like that mom
but her mom's so happy because i found
this dumb idiot he'll do nothing but
love me unconditionally and i can use
him
yeah uh isaac h will they give us the
last two episodes before no way home no
they will give us one more episode
before no way home and then the tuesday
after no way home releases
will be the last one
[Music]
so we'll see
we'll see we'll see we'll see but uh
well that was a great episode we're
gonna get to work it's already
2 a.m
she's got to work tomorrow in the
morning but
if you go subscribe to her youtube
channel perhaps one day she could just
do that full-time and not have to work
and we can talk all night that's facts
let me drop a link for my chat mr
anderson's been dropping the link a lot
oh good for him all throughout the chat
now he don't drop mine because he just
drops alleys yep one or the other
yeah you get one right
can only be one and she's prettier than
me
anybody in the chat on my side including
el hombre
de chica
you can check out her channel right here
um
cat on
marvel minute news
[Music]
uh
and
you guys doing daily updates
hey warren why can't the watch be of jax
the old friend of hawkeye in the comics
i don't think that's likely the old
friend of hawkeye in the comics jax is
jack in
in the sh in the show in the show yeah
kate's mom's fiance from the circus
right yeah from they're not going to do
that clearly because jack and hawkeye
didn't know each other
right whereas he was his mentor in the
comics so they're not going they're not
going down that hi jake thank you so
much
all right guys he dropped your link
chris
hey mr ander he became a member over
here by the way hey there you go yeah
you did today memberships will be up in
the next couple days next time for sure
next time for sure
all right guys anything else ally any
final predictions
kingpin was not in this episode that's
not a prediction that is a statement i
did
i did call yelena was that was the
person in all black i called it before
yeah
all right guys
be sure to subscribe be sure to sub to
chris
that's me
boop
boop and if you want you can sub to me
nah
love you guys thank you so much for
watching this is a lot of fun take care
thank you
thank you to everyone who chatted super
chat or just watching the background we
love you all i'm gonna get started on
the breakdown and we'll see you here
next week
on cosmic wonder woof-woof
on cosmic wonder say
the last thing last thing woof-woof
bye